the dick container and it fell and the
dick rolled out and then they were like
I ain't touching that I ain't gay and
then none of the guys wanted to pick the
dick back up so they're like all right
we're they couldn't hire a game fast
enough that's true because you if you if
the cop touches that then they're
probably gay immediately
[Music]
all right it's JK mystery time
mysterious
gotta figure out how the hell this could
possibly happen mystery in Alabama
There's a gas station parking lot okay
one of my favorite places somebody found
a severed human penis oh on the grounds
of the parking lot how did it get there
what is this right here why is it there
how old was it 24 years old I think is
the penis is 24 years old no no I'm
I don't think they know how long exactly
but it's three inches it's a 24 year
old's penis a deeply closeted man had
gay sex in a bathroom there
and he's very religious and afterwards
he decided he shouldn't have a penis
anymore I'm ashamed of myself
oh that's a good take I think it's a
Alabama Mafia oh sending a message girl
am pay your protection fee yep and then
they throw the dick so it's like horse's
head but in Alabama they do a little bit
oh [__] I like it I'm guessing it's a a
jealous or or a estranged wife who got
mad at her husband for whatever cut off
his dick and then just drove around and
chucked it out the window oh here's a
hint there were no
reports prior or after of anybody
missing their dick really oh is it a
Statewide crime was it a Louisiana dick
this is a federal oh I know this will
buy you it's the Alabama
Mafia and they're a lot you know what we
need a new makeover and people that have
done a ride I think that's a good idea
is the Yakuza and they chop off fingers
we chop off our penis if we mess up we
gotta saying the message oh my God
they're on for making mistakes yeah it's
like seppuku yeah okay I have an idea
it's the Alabama Mafia again
hey that part stays true no matter who's
got it we all agree it's definitely that
right because we already know that's
obviously I've literally never heard of
before three minutes ago they're huge
it's got to be part of the narrative
yeah
okay no I don't [__] well I'm just
counting on these guys
what are you talking about I have an
idea okay
all right tell me elephant okay sorry no
no go ahead Jason no I thought you were
no please Jason go
okay all right
um he's staring at you
um so in the Alabama Mafia okay
got it they they really which is really
bad they looked up to Jeffrey Dahmer
okay yeah so they're like you have to
you know
um cut off
um like Five Guys dick and then so you
can work up the you could be like a
lieutenant in the mafia okay and then
this guy he he's an overachiever so he
started to he's in the gas station and
he cut off like 10 dicks oh whoa yeah
yeah ten and then he he put it in like a
bag like a Walmart bag okay right but
it's a small Walmart bag and then the
cops saw him and he goes you got a bag
of dicks right and he's like not yeah
because there's no code for that for
radio so they have to say the whole
thing yeah yeah you got a bag of dicks
and then the guy who was like I have
yeah I gotta be a lieutenant too
lieutenant and then he runs away and one
dick fell out oh or just to pick up on
this okay it's the Alabama Mafia okay
okay he's got all these dicks in the bag
and he's he's in the bathroom and then
here's police and then he's like oh [__]
and he [__] just starts eating all
the dicks as many as he can if he gets
caught with him that's illegal yeah and
then you know he left one of them
outside yeah but then he left one out
police are like we found no dicks we
found a big empty bag and a little case
open shut it smells funny this bag sure
smells weird in here he didn't want to
get caught right so after he finished
eating a bag of dicks he chopped off his
own put it out there for the evidence
nobody's gonna assume you would eat your
own dick that's real good officer how
could I eat all these pieces I already
have peas
that determines that yeah I believe
there's logic I got another question
yeah what color was the deck white oh
that's the same color as the Alabama
mafia's emblem
was there a fishing string attached to
the penis no there was no fishing that's
an interesting every time the cop tries
to pull it
[Laughter]
there's a weird laughing Bush nearby
we'll investigate that soon that's next
on the ticket we're gonna investigate
that real soon any other questions of
something you might want to know that
might help you actually figure it out so
it's a white is the person that it
belongs to still alive do we know we
don't know who it belongs to right no oh
[__] oh it's a dead dick oh it's a
cadaver definitely a dead dick it's a
cadaver you think it rolled out of the
[__] Mortuary probably a science fan
probably came out of the science man I
was driving by it's bad it's like a
bookmobile maybe it was like a guy that
got in a car accident and then they were
giving a dick replacement because you
know when you're a donor you can donate
organs and then they had like a dick at
the [__] gas station and then the guy
they have a dick at the gas station
that's delivering the dick deliver right
United United penis service they were
out there they're like oh I gotta
[__] go I gotta go get some chips at
the AM PM so then they [__] went
inside and then they tipped over
the [__] dick container and it fell
and the dick rolled out and then they
were like I ain't touching that [__] I
ain't gay and then none of the guys
wanted to pick the dick back up so
they're like all right we're they
couldn't hire a game fast enough yeah
that's true because you if you if the
cop touches that then they're probably
gay immediately yeah so that's why
nobody they just left it in Alabama yeah
come on right with all the homophobic
dudes out there you can you imagine a
truck driver going about that's a
[__] dick I ain't touching that thing
no I wouldn't touch it you know does the
article say but California truck driver
the dick is a grower or a shower
um it it appears to not be a grower oh
that was a shower so it's just a big old
thing just laying there yeah it's like
salami no that's
as a grower I'm very jealous I think it
would lose its ability to grow after
being detached however show is still on
the table here's how here's what
happened the story is actually a lot
sadder and and they'll just don't tell
us now let's stick back to Alabama Mafia
and grosser than you would think you got
the closest though so here's what
happened
that gas station is located like
directly off of a exit from the freeway
okay freeway's right next to it there
was a guy on a motorcycle who lost
control and he got repeatedly hit by a
ton of different cars to the point where
his body literally fell the pieces fell
to Pieces oh my gosh it was like his
dick got detached oh and it was on the
hood of a truck and then that truck
after the situation pulled into that
parking lot and the dick rolled off the
hood I'm gonna need the story to be not
real
I mean how that sounds unreal to even
visualize this is so [__] insane is
it like dark so the cars can't see a
body on the road like you're just
driving your truck and also there's a
[__] penis on the hood of your car
and some guy's body explodes how did
they get this story put together were
they interviewing many people that had
[__] pieces of body everywhere yeah
because the truck driver is like almost
rolled off of my truck this guy just
went like this
it was a thing where a lot of different
people were involved in like when it
happened it was like a like multiple car
collision type situation so they're all
there and when the investigators got
there they put all the pieces together
what happened literally and then once it
had dispersed they didn't know that a
guy had like one of the guys who was
involved who probably didn't get the
worst of it had pulled over to that gas
station so they weren't checking until
much later someone in the parking lot
just was like hey that's a dude when you
say put all the pieces together it's
like put all the pieces of bodies
together and realized oh everything's
there but a dick
and they have to go look for it they
didn't actually take into account
whether or not all you think when a dick
flew on his [__] windshield right
that's what we hit the white washer and
he did that [__] he goes get off he's
like
that wasn't it there's no way gonna be a
dick that wasn't a penis right otherwise
I'd be gay because wasn't there someone
that said that like a dude jumped off
yeah they didn't they were in disbelief
that it was a human that was my friend
yeah he uh yeah he the car in front of
him hit a lady and then that lady's body
hit his windshield and he his brain
immediately made a different story and
was like oh sir yeah like it went to a
defense mode that I guess happens when
you're under like extreme like yeah so
as soon as he saw it he was like he said
that he remembers saying huh why would
there be a bunch a bunch of jars of jam
on the freeway shut the [__] up and then
he stopped at a at a gas station and
cleaned it off without even thinking
like he was just like yeah I wish I had
that power to lose and then he got home
and then just immediately broke down oh
oh my God stop it
raspberry strawberry blueberry dude
that's like when I saw my mom naked when
I was a kid and I was just like oh like
I just saw the blurry Kool-Aid man
that's what that was it was the blurry
Kool-Aid Man
blurry Kool-Aid so that's what it had to
be yeah if you want to survive right you
gotta survive it's survival it's a
survival technique so that could
probably be the case for a lot of people
who were because it's it's weird in this
report that says that's the first few
people that hit him didn't even stop and
then
as you can continue to get hit like it's
such a crazy thing this must be a very
fast moving freeway and they don't know
what happened to this motorcyclist to
have lost control like he was the
Catalyst for why the crash happened
where was this um Alabama oh yeah
I thought it was a different story
because from the mafia yeah
no it's still the mop what's the mafia
have to do with Alabama
I don't know you ever heard of the
Alabama Mafia
[Music]